في العيد في السودان فدوي المدافع لا يزال
يصلح في مختلف ارجاء الخرطوم ونواحيها
خارطه المعارك تتغير بشكل مستمر في ظل
تغير المعطيات على ارض الميدان وبشكل عام
فان الاقتتال لا يزال متمركزا فيما يسمى
بالعاصمه المثلثه والمقصود بها الخرطوم
المدينه والخرطوم بحري او الخرطوم شمال
الى جانب ام درمان في الخرطوم المدينه فان
المعارك الدائره في النقاط الساخنه انتقلت
الى محيطها والحديث هنا عن مطار الخرطوم
ومقر القياده العامه فضلا عن القصر
الجمهوري فاذا كانت قوات الجيش قد نجحت في
وقت سابق في السيطره على المطار نفسه فان
الاقتتال انتشر في محيطه الشيء ذاته في
مقر القياده العامه الذي يشهد محيطه معارك
داريا اما في القصر الجمهوري فان
الاشتباكات مستمره بين الطرفين من اجل
السيطره على المبنى عمليه الكر والفر بين
الجانبين ادت الانتقال الاقتتال الى مناطق
واحياء ايضا ابرزها تلك الدائره على
امتداد شارع الستين في الجزء الشمالي
الشرقي للعاصمه وفي ام درمان وبينما توقف
الاغتال حول محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
شهد شمال المدينه اقتتالا عنيفا بين
الجانبين وتحديدا في جبل السركاب معركه
انتهت بسيطره قوه الجيش على قاعده عسكريه
كانت تابعه لقوات الدعم وفي الخرطوم بحري
فان ابرز الاشتباكات تدور حول معسكر
المظلات الذي تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم
السريعه وفضلا عن النقاط الساخنه للاقتتال
فان الجيش دشن عمليات تمشيط واسعه حيث
جابت دوريات مشاه عده احياء في العاصمه
ونواحيها وسام الذهبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات